california teachers association is one
of those powerful unions in the country
and it is purely an organ of the
democratic party
recently the union held a conference to
discuss how to indoctrinate school
children without their parents knowledge
one first grade teacher called blair
wyatt explained that it's best to hold
meetings for gender identity clubs
during lunchtime so that parents never
know
yes that lunch time is kind of that
sweet spot where the kids don't need to
come earlier stay late and kind of
eliminates
a little bit of that parent interaction
if there are kids who would like to
attend but maybe their parents
are unaware that
um they're interested in participating
or unaware that they are out at school
so if you can get it to happen at lunch
that seems like a really good structure
to you know protect the kids identities
and protect and allow them to attend
amazing that they're admitting this in
public documents from the conference
also show that teachers admit they read
students google search histories looking
for signs of interest in gender issues
so they can take advantage of them we
wouldn't know any of this was happening
if weren't for abigail schar she broke
the story she's the author of
irreversible damage the transgender
craze and a very brave person she joins
us tonight abigail thanks so much for
coming on for breaking this story um
it looks
on the face of it from what we just
presented that these teachers are
intentionally trying to hide what's
going on from the parents of the kids
that's right the deception is actually
the point it's explicit and in fact in
both the reporting i did on that
conference you mentioned in october and
then i've
since seen more recent videos
of the california teachers association
specifically guiding teachers statewide
in deception of parents about the clubs
about the membership that even at the
elementary school level eight and
nine-year-olds telling them to rename
the clubs things like prism club so that
the parents won't know uh what's going
on in the club and won't be able to you
know supervise
since when are teachers allowed to
get involved in these sex lives of minor
children without
the knowledge of the parents it seems
like a crime to me
well you know in one of the videos i
watched uh put out by the california
teachers association the teachers um
instructed other educators that children
as young as seven need support in their
sexual identity um and and they believe
it is their job to provide that and look
if if this were a matter of parents
coming in and saying their child had a
particular sexual or gender identity and
they wanted the school to support it
that would be one thing but instead what
the california teachers association is
doing is they are deciding how to
recruit students to these clubs how to
coach them in in
you know uh solidifying this gender
identity or sex or sexual orientation
identity and they're doing this by
deceiving parents specifically telling
teachers how to keep the existence of
the clubs and the membership from the
parents i mean i assume everyone's going
to leave public schools at a certain
point who can in homeschool or whatever
this is too much but in the meantime is
there anything that can be done to stop
it
you know i i think that that parents
need to get really explicit with kids
about things like gender um and and tell
them what's being taught in schools is
nonsense um and in some cases i you know
if the parents are able to do it they
really should pull their kids out of
these schools because this kind of
nonsense spreads and the teachers look
these are not this is not members of
lgbtq doing this i want to be really
clear about that these are activist
teachers they are looking to peel the
children away from the values of their
homes and supplant those values with
their own
they're grooming seven-year-olds and
talking to seven-year-olds with their
sex lives like we're the dads by the way
so many questions so little time but we
are grateful to you for breaking this as
you have so many stories like it abigail
shara thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else